[Musique]
j'aimerais qu'on met la musique
la première musique qu'ils aiment bien
quand je le vois c'est point soleil
point soleil
[Applaudissements]
la foire est une hanche comme ça à mes
yeux c'est maintenant c'est les
conditions musique je sais pas par
exemple à nous sortir de phil anderson
ouais légèrement violée sébastien
[Musique]
c'est bon
d'abord on a deux attaquants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
windows bac s class est bonne géographie
en plus le ghana le mac et vous avez une
chorégraphie où le tram était sous le
connaissent tellement ringard fera pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
j'étais bouche bée c'est pas un truc
bien en fait
non mais tout ce que je connais depuis
quelques temps normalement bien c'est
moi ou sur l'avant au cul en arrière en
connais jean michel maire ça va être un
gars de nous
[Applaudissements]
k
[Musique]
allez allez lapin
la gâteau en fait elle est appelée vitz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nos débuts 50 des comme ça en boîte sa
minauder ça fait genre non non c est
plus facile à ramener dans c est ce que
dans ses rares et détonne avec ludivine
heures
[Musique]
ouidah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y est
c
[Applaudissements]
les mêmes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous mettre
quelque chose de la guerre de cent ans
[Applaudissements]
ouais
jeudi
m
[Musique]